and Ramez welcome so good to talk to you
about your fantastic book which I
enjoyed thoroughly I found it at work
not only of councilman scholarship but a
page-turner a thrilling adventure read
eminently accessible congratulations on
it well thank you coming from you that
is high praise indeed
you're very kind now of course we'll
talk about the subtitle of your book if
I may quote Henry Folgers obsessive hunt
for Shakespeare's First Folio but I
think it might be helpful originally to
talk about those two men in the context
of their times of course they were if I
may two men both alike in dignity to
quote from Shakespeare and yet separated
by 400 years and the Atlantic Ocean very
very different but they shared one thing
a passion a passion for in the one case
writing the other for collecting but
really put them in the context of their
lives if you would please sure well
Shakespeare was writing around the 1600s
his life was 20 years before 20 years
after the 1600s during the reign of
Elizabeth and James the first and he was
a well-known playwright poet he wrote
sonnets and he was also a businessman he
was a shareholder in a theater company
the globe theatre company in London and
landowner and very well-known in his
time for being a playwright and
businessman Henry Folger was the
chairman first president and chairman of
the board of the Standard Oil Company
the largest corporation in the world and
most reviled corporation in the world at
the time is well during the Gilded Age
and you know Shakespeare wrote these
plays years after he died seven years
after he died two of his friends decided
to create a memorial volume to him and
collected all of the sources they had
available to him and published
thirty-six of the known 38 plays that
Shakespeare grayton and the two men are
connected across time and across the
ocean in that this book that saved half
of Shakespeare's plays from obscure
he became a fetish object for collectors
and Henry Folger this chairman of the
Standard Oil Company wanted to own every
known copy of this First Folio I learned
something very interesting in your book
I thought of the Gilded Age as something
in a you know a very sacred term
referring to it that way but in fact it
was Mark Twain who who coined the term
and he was anything but complimentary
about those who lived in the Gilded Age
that's right he was quite pejorative
about it and in in part the question is
what the new wealthy did to display
their wealth they built these
magnificent mansions in new york and new
porch they had ostentatious collections
of art and and books as well they use
they threw cash around Europe and bought
up European treasures and then brought
brought them back to the States
Henry Folger was quite different than
most of the Gilded Age characters that
we know of JP Morgan
Henry Huntington and alike the he was
quiet unassuming came from very modest
means worked his way up the rungs of the
ladder at the Standard Oil Company but
most of all he never built himself a
mansion until he never owned a house
until he retired from a Standard Oil he
lived in a rented house in Brooklyn with
rented furniture lived a very modest
life and kept secret his obsessive
passion is passion for collecting
Shakespeare Donnelly could have built a
bigger house if he didn't spend so much
money on the manuscripts I can talk
about that but undoubtedly that is true
but he he displayed some of his artworks
at his home but most of the most of the
works that he collected books
manuscripts musical scores musical
instruments costumes playbills and on
and on anything related to Shakespeare
he looked at he studied and then when
the house was full to the brim he would
take them down into the basement wrap
them up put them in a box and then
shipped the box off to a warehouse and
I've looked at receipts
or storage fees for 30 years for some of
the rooms that he rented so one by one
II would fill up these warehouses rooms
with his treasures make an inventory
make a note of which boxes in which room
and over 30 years accumulated room after
room after room in these storehouses in
Brooklyn and Manhattan I think there's a
TV show called hoarders and probably I
wouldn't rise a reason to the level of
that but there's a little element of
that I suppose there is a big element of
that if you if you're a person who's
obsessed with cope with collecting
recyclable bottles or contemporary
newspapers or magazines and you stack
them in your house to where you have to
wind your way through and you can't walk
through your house we might say you have
some kind of a borderline personality or
you know this interferes with your
normal living well Henry Folger
certainly acquired things on that same
scale only the things he acquired were
very valuable and interesting so we
don't call him a hoarder we call them a
magnificent no not the little boxes from
Kentucky Fried Chicken of ten years ago
that's correct now you have a connection
with that collector don't you as well
perhaps your husband do you want to talk
a little about James Swanson a very
well-known author and a bit of a
collector of other memorabilia yes a bit
of a collectors and understatement I'm
being kind you are being damned yes part
of my research on Henry Folger was
informed by the fact that I do live with
a collector and he has been collecting
objects manuscripts books related to
Lincoln since he was 10 years old and he
has amassed an enormous collection that
I have not quite seen the full extent of
because like like Henry James has had to
put many of his objects into storage
because there is no room for them so
he's got storage facilities in more than
one state holding that you know about
that I know right right well and James
also is the author of well number of
books but particularly one of my
favorites manhunt the hunt for John
Wilkes Booth after the Lincoln
assassination but but let's go back in
time a little further than that folio
the first folio could you talk a little
bit about what it folio is it's a phrase
that many viewers may not be familiar
with and then the first folio of
Shakespeare's works and the the two men
you referred to earlier really the the
saviors of Shakespeare's plays sure the
a folio refers to the size of the book
it's very large 13 by 8 approximately
depending on how it's been shaved down
and also the old Time magazine size like
magazines like a wife maybe something
like this size but twice that that's
correct that's correct that would be
closer to that book would be closer to
something called the court oh the size
of house Oleum and what what made it
interesting was a folio size conveys
some kind of gravitas to the work that's
in it and prior to this first folio of
Shakespeare that that size had really
been reserved for political and
religious tracts of some graphic
nonfiction or literature fiction not
literature and certainly not plays which
were not regarded as literature they
were regarded as ephemeral amusements
for the masses the first folio was a
memorial volume that two of
Shakespeare's friends John Hemings
and Henry Condell put together as a
tribute to their deceased friend and how
how long before had he passed away he
died in 1616 and the first folio was
published in 1623 so these items the
idea probably percolated about five
years after Shakespeare's death at which
time only by the time of Shakespeare's
death only half of his plays had been
published so there remained half of the
ER vote that would would not have been
known arguably would not have been known
to history had these two men not said
well let's put these all together in one
volume and save them for posterity
many of the manuscripts possibly even
the only copies of the manuscripts had
gone up in flames at the Globe Theatre
in 16 or what a horrific
story that imagine what the world would
have had if that had not happened that's
and talk a little about how that fire
came about it was somewhat interesting
down a bit reminiscent of some tragedies
we've had in contemporary America
recently yes first folios by the way
also have had a history with fire but
more on that a little bit later The
Globe Theater was like the other
theaters in London trying to attract
patrons it held 1500 people enormous
structure very good size really and one
of the ways that they attracted patrons
was if they added special effects and
one of the special effects might have a
good idea of let's use a real cannon not
like Pixar not computer-generated
generated right so they they shot off a
cannon upon the arrival of I think it
was Henry who Henry the eighth who
arrives during the play during a play
they announced his arrival with a cannon
shot and some of the wadding that was in
the cannon floated up to the thatched
roof of the globe after fire and it
caught fire and burned to the ground in
two hours two hours in two hours the
Great Fire of London is several years
later 1666 but at that time they the
government had had enough and they
outlawed thatched roofs in London until
1994 when the new globe restoration was
completed and they allowed that to have
a faster that's what we're presumably
coated with fireproof yes yes right and
I know cannons being fired in there now
one thing I found interesting was that
the First Folio it required them to get
permission for some of these now under
American copyright law which I used to
practice once an author create something
he or she owns the rights to that
forever unless it's a work-for-hire
and upon their death the estate would
then get that property the value but
Shakespeare had either licensed or sole
the works to other people there was not
copyright and Great Britain until 1709
long after this so the way plays were
paid for was that the theater companies
bought them out rights the globe theatre
company would have paid for the plays
and they would have had the rights both
to perform or to publish and they could
presumably have sold it if they found
found to do that mostly what they did
was in fact exclusively what they did
was they held them very closely there
was a single copy under lock and key at
the theater with a someone who's in
charge of those manuscripts because they
feared that other theater companies
would get copies of them and then take
them out to other cities perform the
plays and not pay them any royalties so
they figured you know if we've got the
rights to Hamlet we want to have the
only copy that's there we don't want
other theater companies performing
Hamlet out in Leeds or which I know from
the movie Shakespeare and love which
presumably contain some historical
accuracies right deal a huge amount of
rivalry between the the players and the
the theatrical companies rising to the
level of a bit of swordplay but perhaps
it was that was exaggerated in the film
but we we know that it was although
popular entertainment extremely rivals
yes there was a lot of competition among
the theatre companies by the end of
Shakespeare's career he retires back to
stratford-upon-avon in 1611 by that time
there are really only two major theatre
companies left in London and part of the
reason for that relates back to the
Puritans prohibiting the the production
of plays they didn't literally shut the
theaters down but that's also
demonstrated in Shakespeare in Love if
the master of the Revels either for
plague or later the Puritans would say
that that plays were you know an
abomination against God pretending to be
something that you weren't and don't do
with men playing the parts of women they
would they were even more included that
great line that woman is a woman a woman
now I was also fascinated as a former
business journalist and I covered the
graphic arts and printing industry to
learn about Jagger
the blind printer fascinating how the
First Folio
was was actually constructed how it was
spent it was massive for one thing nine
hundred Hey
his paper was a problem but talk a
little about that yes let me start at
the end of the story is that without
many copies of the First Folio to
compare it would be very difficult to
draw the inference about how the book
was actually printed so having many
copies available to compare side-by-side
helps you figure out how the copy was
printed you know the long and the short
of it is which by the way is a phrase
from Shakespeare is that the book was
printed from the inside out you didn't
print page 1 and page 2 but then page 3
you printed them in little booklets and
you started with the middle of the
booklet and then you set the type moving
from the inside out that's very hard to
understand but I explained it and I'll
explain it in the book
this meant two things one was that you
had you as the printer had to estimate
how much text would fit on a page that
you'd be able to fit this little booklet
exactly if you had too much room not
such a big problem you could add a
printers ornament something decorative
you could virtually double space the the
text that wasn't a problem if you ran
out of space on the other hand you might
have to print poetry as prose you might
have to cut you excise a line from the
speech Mopars
in order to make the text fit into we
all think that editor the typesetter
says no this isn't the last chapter it
has to go it doesn't fit I mean today if
you were on a you know if you're using
Microsoft Word you would hit justifying
and everything would fit to the space
that you would allotted to it well you
couldn't do that you had to hand set the
type so know one thing I'm very curious
about books today of course we have
hardcover books paperback books that we
have ebooks ebooks enduring as long as
there are bits and bytes and so forth
but the paper in many of today's ebooks
I'm not speaking of literary high
quality literary or art novels but in
popular fiction full of acid it doesn't
last very long I talk about the paper
and actually and we'll talk a little bit
more about the present-day collection of
the folios but talk about if you would
what are they meant what is the
paper made up is it in danger or will it
be in danger in five years ten years 100
years the answer is yes there's some
that the the paper that was used for
printing the first folio was
high-quality rag paper from Normandy
France that was where the best paper
came from and that that is what jacquard
used in printing the first folio and
part of that was to convey the
importance of the volume again to say
this is something important this is
something special
something like a paperback book korto
size which would be at the half the size
of a folio would have been printed on
lower quality paper it would have been
more brittle more acidic and more likely
to sit to disintegrate which is why the
court Oh sighs plays are much more rare
Oh we'll talk about the one that's right
and the folios have survived with pretty
good with pretty good in pretty good
numbers they suffered hazards of time
fire insects infestation infestation yes
people tearing plays out because it was
more convenient to be able to carry one
play around so but all things considered
a pretty good number of them have
survived one thing I found fascinating
was this was a business jagad wasn't
doing this out of the goodness of his
heart he had to really estimate if it
made sense to print X number y number
and then he had to sell them or someone
had to sell them how did of the seven
hundred and fifty copies how did they
get into the stream of Commerce they
were sold mostly out of the printers
shop so printers slash bookseller a
printer bookseller and also all of that
the printing the book selling the paper
warehouses would all have been around
st. Paul's Cathedral in in London so st.
Paul's the square around st. Paul's is
to printing in the 17th century what
Broadway is to theater in the United
States so it would have been the locus
of all of the book shops so that was in
part Geographic accident but in part
planned by the crown because the crown
wanted to know what was being printed
and what ideas were being
so not only the printing presses but the
the booksellers would have been under
the watchful eye of the crown at st.
Paul's
what would a First Folio have cost at
the time at time of publication it would
have cost a pound which was a pretty sum
of money a quarter-sized by contrast for
a single play might have cost five or
six pence and so much cheaper now the
first copy off the press of the
millionaire in the bard is probably
exactly the same as the ten thousandth
copy off the press of the millionaire in
the bargain right that was not the case
of the first folio was it there were
some differences in variations was that
because of the the length differences or
the actual construction of the book
itself well there are two main reasons
one is that corrections to the text were
made while printing was going on so you
might be printing and at page 64 the or
copy number 64 the printer comes over
pulls a proof sheet off the off the the
press and then makes corrections to it
has the type reset to make those
Corrections misspellings for example
sometimes they put the actor's name
instead of the name of the character and
so we had to correct that on the fly
then that proof sheet would be stacked
with the other pages and then later
collated into the copies and then the
new pages that were printed off would
would have the corrected version so for
every page there was there was a single
proof sheet some uncorrect and then some
corrected version so if you you know
sort of multiply that up by 900 pages
doing this 900 times every copy is
slightly different so a jacquard taken
over at this point we see the one
overseeing that over Hema jism Cadell
very involved in that as well Hemmings
and con Del's work was primarily
beforehand so they would have taken the
sources available to them the already
printed or already published versions of
the plays that had been available in
court oh they edited them they had acted
in these plays with Shakespeare they
were you know had been friends with him
for a long time so
they knew how the plays had been acted
so they could look at for example one of
the core toes of Hamlet that had been
published and say oh no no that's not
how it was this is how it was and then
edit it into the version that we more
commonly know that that we know from the
first folio so they would have used
manuscripts that they would have had
available to them as members of the
theater company and then their their
memorial recreations and this all would
have been in in in in how they had
edited essentially these plays once the
manuscripts were trans transcribed by
probably by Ralph Crain they got to the
printers shop and then it was probably
not so much Isaac who was blind at this
time but his son who would have done the
corrections on yes
now the what I'm think you know is
Shakespeare to my surprise did not
really become hugely popular until
sometime after his death I mean he was a
well-known Elizabethan and Jacobean
playwright of course and people enjoyed
his work but it was 140 years I believe
until his popularity began to soar what
happened to the first folios in that
time were they marginalized or did
people truly recognize that someday this
would be a valuable book
I don't know that the collectors or
actors or producers thought at the time
someday people will recognize how great
this is
in fact over that period of time we had
the English Civil Wars during what the
the Puritans took over Parliament and
then they prohibited plays from being
produced which meant that there were no
new plays being written and the old
plays were not being performed so it was
quite some time not until the
restoration that Shakespeare's plays
again come back to the stage and by then
public tastes have changed a little bit
the producers of the play start to
change the endings
yes and one was that several movies made
in Hollywood I know how that was right
Hester Prynne walks
which aureus at the end with a machine
gun on him whether it right exactly
well a particular actor owned a copy of
a folio man named David Garrick and he
was a very well-known tragic actor he
edited the plays himself producing them
in London for example Romeo and Juliet
he produced alternate nights with happy
endings or sad endings he can imagine a
few of the plays he cut an act or two to
keep the narrative moving a whole Act in
fact in Twelfth Night I think he could
he cut two acts to keep the narrative
linguistics the sixth night the sixth
night right and so the by the time we
get to the one hundred and fifty years
after Shakespeare's death the plays are
quite different than what we remembered
and it's really by going back to the
first folio that we have a good idea of
how they would have been performed at
the time that Shakespeare was still
alive well this brings up a very
interesting point of course we're
speaking primarily the first folio but
there were other folios as well and I
found fascinating in the I think it was
the third folio all of a sudden one
would be familiar to let's say with the
first folio you you see a copy of the
third folio open it up seven new plays
only one of which was apparently a
attributable to Shakespeare where did
the others come from and talk a little
about the other folios well there were
four folios altogether they're like four
editions each of them got further and
further away from the original text as
Hemings and Condell had edited the play
so again they would have acted in these
plays have known how they had been acted
there are hundreds of mistakes that are
introduced into the later folios and
essentially first folio sells out in
nine years a second folio is produced
third fourth mmm they add these
apocryphal plays to which you you refer
imagine if I could dig into my attic and
say I found one of manuscript of Harper
Lee's fourth novel and fifth novel and
then I you know 50 years posthumously or
20 years posthumously I published them
as her
well that's what was going on they
thought they could make a little extra
money by saying ah the fourth folio is
better than the first by this one well I
will talk about enry Folgers acquisition
of a fourth folio at one point but they
must have had some intrinsic value
though for true collectors they were
someone who taught to have maybe the
whole panoply of folio is it possible
yes and there are certainly collectors
like Huntington and Morgan and Folger
who wanted to own a complete set over
everything
most of those collectors wanted the high
spots a really good quality copy of one
of each Folger wanted every copy he
could get his hands on it good copy bad
copy with graffiti in it missing plays
with torn pages with you know insect
board holes and them the rusty outline
of scissors or eyeglasses and the more
people have left the the volume shut for
years he wanted them all now I have to
bring up something that's something that
agrees no I'm not gonna charge your
royalties for this however I should let
you know as you and I have talked before
let the viewers know my last name is
Deaver and I am according to my family
genealogists descended from the 17th
Earl of Oxford Oxford Edward de verre
who was within the it's called the anti
Stratfor dee ins is that the correct way
to pronounce it that's it the conspiracy
theorists who feel that Shakespeare did
not in fact write the place he was sort
of a frontman
I do not subscribe to that so I'm not
going to hit you up for any royalties as
I say from my part in the Shakespeare
the whole Shakespeare story but talk a
little bit about that because people do
find it fascinating right so broadly
it's called the authorship question did
Shakespeare really write those plays and
as you say there's a group of people who
have various candidates for whom they
believe actually wrote the plays that
are attributed to Shakespeare and
they're few things that are important to
know one is that in his lifetime nobody
doubted that Shakespeare had written
those oh is that right it was a hundred
and fifty years before someone said oh I
don't think this man really wrote the
plays if you go back to
stratford-upon-avon there isn't
voluminous evidence
even his existence they're there no for
example grammar school records that show
that he went to the grammar school there
there's there he didn't go to university
how could he have written these plays
without a university education so the
Earl of Oxford is one of the candidates
Christopher Marlowe is another Francis
Bacon was the most popular he's Delia
bacon in the mid 1800s wrote a book
essentially purporting but that Francis
Bacon had written no relation to her by
the way had written had written these
plays and it had not been anyone named
William Shakespeare miss bacon has a
very interesting story of her own she
went to England
supposedly to research the authorship
question she didn't actually do any
research she went to the town and
absorbed the atmosphere but didn't do
any interviewing or are we fiction
writers to that'll just absorb they just
go there and absorb the the atmosphere
she didn't end so well although her her
book the was had an introduction written
by Nathaniel Hawthorne who regretted for
the rest of his life that he had written
a the the introduction because he not
actually read the book she ended up in
an insane asylum at the end of her life
so she had an interesting life on her
own that alone doesn't mean that her
hypothesis is incorrect however we have
a lot of evidence that Shakespeare
existed in stratford-upon-avon he lived
in London he wrote plays his
contemporary playwright bellows wrote
about him as a playwright and he acted
in the plays he acted in the plays the
English were tremendously accurate
record keepers and someone called the
master the rebels would have kept a
record of not only what plays were
performed at court but who had written
the plays and who had acted in the men
Shakespeare's mentioned in their dozens
of times
so Elizabeth and James Queen Elizabeth
and James the first would have known who
Shakespeare was and whose plays they
were John Webster and the preface to the
white devil writes about his friend
William Shakespeare play ripe and Jonson
comic writer at the time wrote
in the preface to the First Folio and
elsewhere you know compliments about his
friend William Shakespeare so we we have
a lot of information about connecting
Shakespeare tonight I did have to point
out to my cousin who was as I say the
avid conspiracy or anti strand 40 and
because of our namesake of course he was
a diva as well that Edward de verre died
before Macbeth was first performed
before the tempest Henry the eighth's
several other players as well and he
said well but but Edward de Vere could
have written them and hidden them under
his under his bed or in a in a cottage
somewhere right so that showed a maze
impressions on the part of the Earl of
Oxford that he continued to have plays
published years after he died very very
smart but no please go ahead what you
mentioned Macbeth the the most important
feature of the first folio is that it
saved half of Shakespeare's plays from
extinction from that era
we have diarists and records from the
master of the Revels of about twice as
many places we actually have copies of
and by the time Shakespeare had died
only half of the plays had been
published and were sort of secured well
not a hundred percent secure for from
being extinct but it was Hemmings and
Condell who published the other half of
these plays and arguably without that
book those plays would have been lost to
history plays like Macbeth there would
have been no tomorrow and tomorrow and
tomorrow there as you like it no
Rosalind The Tempest no Caliban no
Prospero no Julius Caesar no Coriolanus
no antion Antony and Cleopatra and on
and on so some of the most important
plays that we know from Shakespeare no
high schooler would be studying Macbeth
it if they are really the unsung heroes
of English literature that they saved
half of these plays from extinction and
don't we have the First Folio to thank
for the won't one extant
picture of Shakespeare we do there are
two
Edge's of Shakespeare one is an effigy
made out of plaster that is in the
chancel at stratford-upon-avon but that
was commissioned after Shakespeare's
death although it was seen by his family
members who would have said oh no that's
not what he looked like if it had been a
problem but Hemmings and Condell
commissioned a Flemish engraver
to make an image which would be the
title page of the first folio by that by
the way this is really the first time
the author's picture was on the title
page in such a prominent position they
would have provided some kind of
secondary source sketch or painting or
something that we don't know and then
Druce out would have engraved this and
then shown it to Hemmings in Condell and
they could have said you know a little
more hair a little less hair you know
bigger mustache whatever it was like a
police sketch artists although they
would probably have had to do that with
the original the source that the
engraver was working from because it
would be really hard to erase from a oh
yes from a copper engraving but but at
least Hemmings in Condell who did know
Shakespeare would have seen the image
and could have said oh no that's not
what he looks like at all now we've been
talking about England the British Isles
let's cross the pound a bit of course
Shakespeare and theatre in general did
not catch on quite as much certainly in
colonial days until much much later I
had this wonderful quote from your book
about the Puritan increase Mather who
said this persons who have been
corrupted by stage plays are seldom and
with much difficulty redeemed so it took
a little while for Shakespeare to get
some footing in America how long did
that take in fact it takes about a
century and for almost the same reasons
that some of the plays would have
disappeared in England and that is that
the Puritans who had shut down the the
production of plays in England were the
ones who came to the colonies and they
would not allow place to be produced
here either so it took about a century
before Shakespeare started to become
even out on the frontier was read and
then perform so tell us about the
confluence of William Shakespeare and
Henry Folger
when did he become interested and when
did he really start to get an inkling
that I need to possess this man's plays
I I think it happens as as with many
collectors over a period of time it
started he was studying the plays at
Amherst College
he heard Ralph Waldo Emerson deliver a
lecture and then became interested in
Emerson read his Emerson's lecture on
Shakespeare and thought okay this is
worth some closer study and for the rest
of his life he read the plays they
affected him personally he thought
Shakespeare had really captured modern
man and amazingly modern man is not that
different in 1880 than he is in fourteen
four hundred years later I'm sorry four
hundred years earlier so from the plays
inform him about love and life and
jealousy and competition as they do us
oil tea as they'd ever thought because
everything part one is you really like
the place part two is once he had a
little bit of income in his pocket he
started to collect copies of the folio
as you mentioned the first one that he
acquires at bangs auction ordinary isn't
it and that that's hammered down to him
at a hundred and seven dollars and fifty
cents and he has to pay for that over
time he doesn't have enough money to pay
for that no matter where was he at that
point cuz we know went to law school as
well even while he was in law school he
would have his law books and then
reading fiction and often a author that
had been influenced by Shakespeare
Goethe Schiller Victor Hugo and so forth
Carlisle yes Carla what no was at that
point when he acquired his his first
well his fourth folio was he indeed a
student or was he working at that point
he was already working but he was also
known to carry around copies of the play
in his pocket and on his time on the
streetcar going back and forth between
Brooklyn and lower Manhattan he would
have been reading the Shakespeare plays
he and his wife Emily also went to many
Shakespeare performances in New York so
he enjoyed watching the plays
the plays and then eventually he
encountered Shakespeare scholars once he
was sort of an established collector he
would write back and forth with some of
the Shakespeare scholars and discuss the
text and how was this part performed and
how strong was Lear in this in this
scene was a near madness or was he still
sure so this was definitely more than
just possessing an object right he was
involved in the whole milieu of the
Shakespearean world from from the
portfolio's are from the folios to the
acting to the theatre production and so
on talk about one of the mysterious
acquisitions in his life that his first
first folio we don't know a lot about
that do we yes ironically for a man who
saved many many scraps of paper and
thousands upon thousands of letters over
the 4050 years that he was writing you
know very little about the very first
acquisition we know it's around 1881 to
1882 we know its condition but we don't
really know how we don't have a record
of how much he paid for it for example
now I was absolutely enthralled with
your description of rare manuscript
collecting of the era that gilded age
presumably much of it still continues
today how people would want an
unsophisticated manuscript an unwashed
manuscript we find disparaging terms
elsewhere but certainly not to the
manuscripts there were agents and spies
involved talk a little about that if
you're sure these the the first folio is
really exceptional in the book
collecting world in that a copy that is
missing plays missing pages is damaged
in number of ways missing its original
titled page missing its cover in bad
shape it's still desirable to collectors
and if you had that for for example a
manuscript of Jack London's White Fang
you probably wouldn't be interested it's
missing pages and you know you would
probably not be interested in that as a
collector the first folio is exceptional
in that collectors want doesn't matter
what the condition is the price changes
if it they they want copies no matter
where they are and that
a little bit of a fetish object although
as I've said before although folger did
wasn't incredibly acquisitive and he
wanted every one of these copies it was
not just as a fetish object he actually
did read the place now I'm in one of
your wonderful stellar reviewers one of
the many seller reviews of your book I
can't remember what publication it was
but it referred to the basically three
men and a woman who we have to thank for
this wonderful fine heavens Cantrell and
then of course Henry Folger but his wife
Emily whom you referred to I
she was instrumental in the collection
process wasn't she she was the the
review was Stephen Greenblatt in New
York time on that and Hemings of Condell
again without them editing the plays we
would not know half of the plays that we
do today Emily was the unsung hero in
for two reasons one is if you're an
obsessive collector and you're you're
running the world's largest corporation
during the day and you come home at
night and you sift through catalogues
and even when you go on vacation you
bring your inventory of your collection
with you just in case something comes up
and you need to find out if you have a
better copy or an inferior copy and
should you order it it's very helpful to
have a spouse who shares that passion
with you otherwise soon it interferes
with most and that yes and she shared
his passion both for Shakespeare she had
written her master's thesis on the true
texts of Shakespeare she was not a
dilettante either and she also
participated on a daily basis and going
through the catalogues and making
inventories of what was in their
collection
and suggesting to Henry what it is that
they should buy she also attend attended
many of the performances of the plays
and kept a diary of that as well and
that made her a an exceptional partner
in this pursuit of Shakespeare iana so
Henry lucked out and this wife who
really was very compatible with him on
that second though is that at the time
that Henry died in 1930 the stock market
had already crashed October 29 and the
value of the endow
that he plan to leave behind fund the
library had been cut by about 40% and
had Emily not been as generous with her
own money in the the library would never
have been completed really so after his
death the finances were not as as
generous as they as Henry had expected
that they would be and without Emily
participating in and giving her money to
the building of the library it would not
have opened now my impression was that
when Henry and Emily first got started
in this they were more devoted to the
folios in the Shakespeare iana itself
than to the art of collecting they made
some some mistakes they he had some
disappointments in fact I think he tried
it didn't he try to talk rockefeller
into purchasing a huge body of work a
library of work and suggesting that
Rockefeller could and then enter the
public to make some money defray the
cost enter the publishing world to sell
little pocket books of these which did
not work out but but talk about some of
his how he stumbled a little bit how he
got his feet well that that was the case
of a man who was very talented financial
brinksmanship but could not have scraped
together the money to buy this entire
collection that had gone up for sale and
he wrote a letter we don't know if he
actually sent this to rockefeller but I
suspect he spoke to him about this
saying hey you've just endowed the
University of Chicago Yale has got a
collection of first folios others
Harvard's got first folios maybe
University of Chicago would like to have
a great collection of Shakespeare iana
and I'd be willing to go through the
collection with you and tell you which
are the most valuable pieces and which
should be reproduced and you could sell
them and defray the cost of acquiring
the collection so that did not work
Rockefeller did not buy that buy that
and it went to a competitor Marsten
Perry and he was I assume a bit miffed
about that Bulger was yes ultimately
some of that collection finally did get
to folder so 1907 there's a financial
panic and
Mars and Perry sir suffers a loss of a
tremendous collection of Shakespeare
iana to Henri Huntington and he says uh
if I can't get the best I'm just gonna
give up the Shakespeare thing altogether
and he started selling off his his
collection as well until ultimately
Henry Folger did get some of that
collection now one of the most thrilling
accounts in your book is of a particular
manuscript and if I may quote it has
been described as the single most
valuable and desirable copy of the first
folio in the world that was Augustine
Vincent's and apparently Augustine
Vincent a contemporary of Jagger who
apparently handed him gave him the the
copy in person and it ended up in the
collection of let's see
Constance B SYP SYP Thorpe is that
cramming this behind is on a name for
short okay thank goodness it was kind of
because that's the name you could not
certainly not make up but that
acquisition had it's true ups and downs
could you talk about it in the shorts
Folger became aware of the existence of
this superb copy complete with all the
original leaves from one copy of the
fold of the folio it had not been
supplied by from another copy or
anything like that was very tall had it
a part of its original 17th century
cover within the modern cover that had
been put on it and we knew its
provenance we knew who had owned it from
the get-go so it was the only
presentation copy that we know of of the
Shakers first folio given by the printer
to his friend office know what is that
presentation copy refer to just that we
know that the either the author or the
publisher gives a copy to a specific
person and the the two that we know of
one is to Augustine Vincent and if you
look at the end papers of the book it
has that presentation copy with the
inscription by the the printer in it the
other presentation copy would have gone
to the bodily and library at Oxford
which was mandated you know essentially
same way and deposit copies that
incident to if we have a chance but go
on about the sixth or Foe acquisition
Folger becomes aware of this copy
because a census is published in 1903 by
an English Shakespeare scholar and then
for four years he chases after the copy
he finds out how much does this guy want
for this superb copy it's a lot of money
shakes a Folger says well could I buy it
over time could I look at it on approval
that's a lot of money and by the time
he's made up his mind and maybe he's
been able to scrape together the
financial wherewithal to buy the the
volume the Englishman who owns the copy
says well I've changed my mind
I'd rather have the book to look at them
a check but if you write to me once a
year around Christmastime asked me if
I've changed my mind Folger to do that
in a son putting the onus on him to get
in touch with that correct so you come
and ask me you know genuflect and ask me
if I'm ready to sell my book or not and
then at some point actually SIPP Thorpe
writes to folder and says well someone
else has offered me some money you write
rights to a book dealer and tells him
somebody else has offered me money for
this and that information gets back to
Folger and he says well if you'd be
willing to offer me ten thousand pounds
which was an enormous sunburn was the
record price for a book at the time and
Folger again had some perhaps some
financial difficulty in getting all the
money together at once and demurred a
little bit and can I pay for it over
time almost lost it but I am in the end
did see it's a real roller coaster when
you follow this story in the book your
your palms are sweating to see so you
can snatch it away from him now there's
an opportunity to get it again right
well the idea was to to have you go on
on the same ride that Henry did which
was you don't know whether he's gonna
end up with a copy or not and it is
suspenseful and you're just I was at
least was rooting for him they told the
court he would ultimately get the copies
though but that brings up an interesting
point oh my gosh we have so much to talk
about but this was as I was reading the
book I was thinking my initial reaction
well you know here's the
it's and this is their there boy their
star playwright and here's an upstart
Yankee hoovering up all of these first
folios would there never be any backlash
but indeed there was some some backlash
and I think that was the manuscript you
were referring to is that right it
happens twice there is there is a copy
that is owned by the bodily and library
and when the Bob lien acquired a
subsequent folio second or third folio
they decided to sell their first folio
as surplus so it's gone and years later
some collector comes in to the Bob lien
and asks them can you verify that this
is a first folio well they look at this
they look at the unique cover which
contained a hasp that a chain would have
gone through and the chain would have
been attached to a shelf so that
somebody could have read the book but
they would have to stand there and read
it they couldn't steal it no and this is
unique to these copies that are at the
Bob lien library all bound by a man
named William wild goose another great
English name we have had some
interesting names in our conversation
today yes there are there are short
version of the story is the Bob Liam
wanted to buy this copy back from this
collector and the collector named a
price of 2,000 pounds and Folger said
where do I send the cheque oh well I
want to buy that copy I'll take it right
now and meanwhile the bottling was
trying to raise money to be able to buy
it back for its own collection yeah and
articles appeared in the newspaper and
The Times Literary Supplement and notes
and queries this for the book collecting
world newspapers saying won't anybody
you know pony up the money to buy this
oscillate yes absolutely where are they
you know Oxford men are not phoning up
the money to buy this back some
Cambridge men have even given some money
you have inferred and in one of the
newspapers cartoon was published of a
faceless millionaire because they didn't
know who it was who the American
collectors anonymous it was anonymous he
was going through his book dealer
southern in London
and it was a portrait of someone like
moneybags from the board game Monopoly
of course man clasping bags of cash and
looking at English treasures who is this
faceless millionaire and there was a
great deal of backlash that these
treasures were being brought overseas
the second time that happened was
following Henry Huntington's acquisition
of Gainsborough's Blueboy and Folgers
acquisition of the Vincente copy cartoon
appeared with Uncle Sam with blue boy
under one arm and a First Folio under
the second arm and looking over at
Shakespeare's bones in his grave and
thinking I'd like to bring those back to
America as well so this was this Fleet
Street press was yes they were they were
not happy that the the Americans with a
lot of cash were coming and buying their
cultural treasures and liberating books
from the dusty libraries of the
aristocrats of England and taking them
back to the United States well our time
is racing along I can't believe it's
gone by so quickly and I do have a few
other well have many other Shakespearean
questions but I do want to turn the
tables just a bit here you in your book
have a lovely dedication to your mother
and to your father who if I remember
correctly I'm not quite phrasing it
exactly right but who enlisted in His
Majesty's Navy to defend Shakespeare's
England I found that very touching well
let's talk about you a little bit Andrea
if you would please I know you have
economics degrees you teach economics
now I think you were a protege of Frank
McCourt were you not that's right of
well my favorite writers personages talk
a little about that and also how you
came to write the book okay I
my father's English and he joined the
Navy at age 17 and he and his brother
fought during World War two that's where
the dedication comes from he by the way
it took me to stratford-upon-avon when I
was a teenager I guess that was my first
is that when the bug caught yeah I was
probably the the kernel the kernel the
storytelling
came from Frank McCourt and his mentor
who is one of my high school teachers
who taught me Shakespeare and Jacobean
literature he was a quintessential
storyteller and it didn't matter what it
was about he could tell a great yarn and
taught us about how to develop dramatic
tension and how to tell a good tale book
does because as I mentioned in my
remarks and I believe it was another
review I read so many of them all
glowing it called it a page-turner and
it really is
notwithstanding being a former attorney
I am working on a law review when I was
in school I appreciate footnotes and you
are as meticulous about footnotes as
anything else but that does not affect
the readability of the book it is just
at page turning adventure tale
absolutely is now one thing I would like
to talk about you deluded to it before
if any viewers are familiar with Folger
at all prior to our discussion or prior
to reading your book they would think of
the Folger library of course and you
mentioned that a little bit but how many
tons of Shakespeare iana did Folger have
toward the end of his life he knew he
wanted it to have a home and how the
Folger library came about is rather
interesting so could you tell us a
little bit about that sure Henry and his
wife Emily
were friends with a Shakespeare scholar
Howard Furness at University of
Pennsylvania and it was he that
suggested to Henry hey I built a library
not just pack these things away in books
he would ask and for example well how
many copies you have or do you have a
copy of this that I can look at and he
would say well it's all the way in
storage I can't get to it
dozens of librarians and scholars wrote
to him and said oh you know you have
this copy first quarto of Hamlet can I
have a look at it and he would say well
sorry it's all packed away and the idea
came to him certainly by the turn of the
century he should build the library and
make this available to scholars just one
question if I may interrupt did he have
a catalog did he know everything he had
he the answer's no Emily cataloged all
of the books she wrote hand wrote index
cards detailing you know what the
publication was
and what the condition was where they
bought it what the price was and so on
those those index cards still exist but
he didn't catalogue everything and in
part because it started arriving in such
great volumes that he couldn't keep up
with it he would buy watercolor
paintings by the boxful by the crate
full and it was not all catalogued in
fact there's so many individual items at
the Folger library that they're still
not all cataloged right also we have
this mass of material so so please go on
with the library King Henry and Emily
consider building the library in New
York City but with their modest
relatively modest endowment they cannot
afford real estate there some things
never change yes and Emily had grown up
in Washington DC her father had worked
for the Abraham Lincoln Treasury and she
was familiar with Washington and on one
of their train trips to West Virginia
for vacation they stopped by and they
looked around at the property on Capitol
Hill and they said huh this would be a
good place I wonder how much it would
cost to do that and you know the end of
the story is they bought the property
here and were able to build the library
with the money that they had out there
was a little drama about the property
wasn't it there was it took a total of
nine years to buy up all of the town at
14 townhomes on East Capitol Street
between second and third by the time he
finished acquiring all of the properties
the Congress had made a decision to
expand the Library of Congress which is
across the street and they were going to
use eminent domain to take the property
that Henry had just acquired so imagine
he's been nine years acquiring the
property looks in the newspaper Congress
is going to take the property so he
enlisted the help of the librarian of
Congress this is after all the president
of Standard Oil that is writing the note
and saying hey are you going to take
this property I would
I won't build a library if you're going
to take and condemn the property and the
librarian of Congress named Putnam
helped him deal with Congress in carving
out the parcel that he had purchased
from the acquisition that the Library of
Congress made so the Library of Congress
expansion building is behind the Folger
library oh they managed to work it out
they managed to work it out well I would
encourage viewers to go there I've been
there many times and in fact they have a
wonderful gift shop at which I bought
the medieval cookbook and hosted a
medieval banquet for about 40 or 50
people and it was a was a great time yes
and turkey legs were thrown at each
other it was a great time doing that now
we are almost out of time but I do have
a question for you you described
yourself or at least the copywriter on
the back of this book describes you as
obsessive and mirroring Henry Folger of
course how many extent first folios are
there accounted for both at the Folger
library that is within Henry's
collection and elsewhere around the
world there are 82 copies at the Folger
library the next largest collection just
for means of comparisons is it may say
University in Japan and that is twelve
oh my the next largest after that is the
British Library and that is five so it
is not common for people to have a dozen
or more copies of first folio we know of
as of November of last year we know of
244 copies of the 750 that we think were
originally printed so there is out there
somewhere a first folio for you oh that
would be delightful
I could probably afford a page of a
first folio how about maybe you'll do
some detective work and find one in a
barn somewhere and maybe I will maybe I
will there's some cipher there that will
lead me to the lost manuscripts of
Shakespeare there are few plays that we
know about that he wrote that we don't
have copies of so there still be curious
are things still being discovered is
that possible yes in fact copies of the
first no manuscripts have been
discovered there we do not have a single
manuscript in in Shakespeare's hand but
copies of the first folio have recently
gone for between five and six and a half
million dollars so well many librarians
flip through their their inventories and
say maybe I have one out there as well
and in fact a French University it's
near Calais recently discovered a copy
last year discovered a copy and had it
verified that that is number 240 oh very
exciting well I see our time is up and I
wish you luck in your quest
Andrea Mayes a pleasure talking to you
thank you